he's the new head coach of the atlanta
falcons joining me here on this uh
wednesday program he's arthur smith how
are you coach
you're doing great rich how are you
doing i'm doing fine i noticed you
called like we were expecting you at 9
20 or something so i'm i'm uh pacific uh
12 20 eastern
uh we're a couple minutes late for you i
apologize but you were also a few
minutes uh
a few minutes early so uh do you have
that coughlin time
thing going i was just not trying not to
waste your time richard
oh my gosh gotta be at one time oh
i apologize if i'm wasting your time i'm
not at all okay
here's the story okay no good great i
appreciate that because i never know
when coaches are being
passive-aggressive with me or that's
just my own
i'm direct rich
[Laughter]
all right so then let's get right into
it uh coach when did the falcons appear
on your radar screen
when did that happen for you well yeah
right when uh
our season ended um you know we'd set up
a
zoom you know everything was kind of
like i was joking it was kind of like
speed dating and he had all these zoom
interviews where
it's mine are saying years past the team
might have flown in or
that would have phoned me in just to
start the first interview so
it was uh it was definitely interesting
got to talk to a lot more people by
doing the zoom
but right after that monday after our
season ended so how
because i know meetings uh pre-pandemic
would take hours
and you know and obviously presentations
that you would have already
um is that how long like what what is an
interview through
a head coaching interview through zoom
like so
what is that like coach they were all
different uh depending on the team
and how they structured them i mean both
of them they had a an outline of you
know questions they wanted to hit and it
just depended how many people were on
the zoom call
uh but you know the thing that probably
helped the most is
since march of last year everybody has
adapted to zoom we certainly use it i'm
sure every
uh nfl and college team in some way
shape or form so it's pretty familiar
with the format
would have been a lot different if we've
done this a year ago and i didn't know
what zoom was but
right okay and so uh who's your coaching
influence
who's that i've had a lot of i've been
very fortunate i
you know i was in tennessee for a long
time was a part of a lot of different
staffs
uh certainly you know coming from
college i was coached by
a guy that had a lot of nfl ties and
john bunning
and john had been around he's been a
dick for a meal guy you know
and he was influential to me at this to
teach me to you know his his perspective
of the nfl and then
i got to washington got to work for joe
gibbs um
i stayed on to the gym jim zorn
transition
and then when i got to tennessee mike
uh munchek wooden hot mike malarkey mike
grebel and then i'm leaving out a bunch
of assistants but
i've been i've been fortunate i've been
a lot of different staff so but
you know when uh when you i i have a
guest on and i
uh first time i'm interviewing you and i
kind of look up your history
there is a period in between the
washington uh time
and then when you uh appeared at ole
miss what were you doing
uh were you still trying to stay in
football were you i was you know i did
you know in washington a
big part of it was it i had a great
experience there was was
trying to transition out of there and
going somewhere there was no influence
of
my father so that was really i was
looking for another job i had a great
you know it's good when you get into the
entry level but really to make on your
own you want to be somewhere to kind of
separate yourself
yeah your your dad is the the founder of
uh of fedex
right arthur correct okay so do you like
things done overnight is that basically
the way you grow up or
i mean how does that well i mean you
certainly learned a lot almost
right it depends what it is i mean i
don't think you know i try not to be a
snap judgment guy and try to think
things through but certainly
sped up the world that's for sure i know
it must have been interesting working in
fedex field too
just all over the place i don't know
you're making sure that the the signs
are all perfect as well as getting your
job done so i got
i got i got arthur smith here on the
rich eisen show
and obviously uh you know you got your
hands full um
coming from tennessee with everything
that you've done there and now
the concept would be to replicate your
success there
uh in atlanta how much of a conversation
um in your zoom talking to atlanta was
the the future of matt ryan
and your plan on that well it's really
all the guys on the roster i mean when
you when you start over at a place
uh there's obviously guys here that have
been very successful
that we're excited to work with but
there's a lot of a lot of different
factors when you're going in
uh you know each job different where
you're at i mean this place obviously
matt ryan's been here and he's had a lot
of success
you know as hula jones has and a lot of
other
players that have been here for a while
but you know you just got to take
everything into consideration
and know there's there's going to be
changes as we go through the spring with
with terry and i and
even in the summer yeah terry font no
the the new general manager brought over
from the saints organization so
i'll just be more direct what is matt
ryan's future with your team
well the same feature every other player
on this team and we're going to evaluate
everything we're excited about working
with matt
but uh i can't predict the future right
now for you rich but uh
we got to get into it and that's and and
i'm giving an honest answer here terry
there's so much work to be done as you
get through this roster uh and and i
guess the the question about
matt is it has nothing to do with his uh
bona fides as a as a falcon or a
a quarterback who can win in the nfl i
don't think that's
at all the case but we have seen what
you did
with ryan tannehill just as a for
instance
and how dynamic uh his play was
in your care running as much as throwing
uh
many times you're on the goal line and
uh or in the red zone in the 10-yard
line and in and you got that battering
ram and derek henry and sometimes you'd
use tannehill to run it and that doesn't
appear to be ryan's game can ryan work
in your system
in your estimation coach we're going to
adapt to the strength of
the players um you know and we'll see
we'll see if we'll break out the speed
option with matt
um and you know it certainly did it in
high school um
but there's a lot of things in in in
being serious i mean there's
things like taking this job it's not
like we're bringing derek henry with us
over here either
so you've got to adapt to who you've got
you know whether you've got more guys
out there
at receiver or tight end running back
you've got to be flexible
so walk me through what it's like to
call a play for derrick henry
arthur what is that pretty easy yeah
we've got a guy that can take it 99
yards
94 yards which i've seen him do it
backed up uh you know i'd like to sit
there and say it that was a great play
call
but then it's like watching a great home
run hitter yeah
and then uh did you teach him how to
stiff arm arthur or you think that's
really much innate with him what do you
think
well do something that derek worked on
and certainly something that we
emphasized and yes tony dude is running
back coach they worked on a ton
uh yeah derek got a powerful stiff arm i
think you know sometimes during the
years
you can see there's certain guys the way
they tackle they're like they just
didn't want to be a meme
to be on the internet
[Laughter]
unfortunately they didn't want to be but
it's too bad sometimes you don't get
what you want i mean my god
um he is truly one of the more unique uh
runners and uh in your final regular
season game of the year
it looked like he had i mean it's not
looked like he definitely had an
opportunity to
set not only the single season record
for most yards in a season but
single game record for most yards in a
game i mean
uh and again uh i'm i'm just wondering
what it is like to be an offensive
coordinator and a system and know that
you have
uh number 22 running like and how that
actually
uh made your job what easier or
more fun i'd love to give you the floor
on that
yeah it certainly was fun i mean
obviously you know uh
just watching him in certain games that
all you know always think back with
great memories you know last year
in the new england game up in the
playoffs uh you know it was like
watching a
a boxer take over it was just over and
over and really those guys up front
i mean they were rolling out the ball
and derricking and it
was fun to watch and then the playoff
game against baltimore and
there's so many times during the years
or when he's changed the game
it's just different when you get a guy
you know you call a run
and he takes off and goes 75 plus i mean
that certainly changed
the kansas city regular season game in
19 um
and there's just so many plays you can
think about but
it's exciting when you know that every
time you can hand the ball off it could
be a home run
arthur smith few minutes left with the
new head coach of the atlanta falcons
here
uh on the on the rich eisen show okay
so what what is the role of analytics we
hear so much
honestly sometimes i'm sitting there
watching the game i'm like why are they
going for two or
why aren't they going for two or fourth
down why aren't they going in here and
then you hear
well that improves ten percent chance of
this five percent chance less for that
how much is that a role in in what
you've presented to
uh arthur blank and what you plan on
also putting on the field for the
falcons
coach yeah it's all part of it part of
the decision i think the more
information you can you can have
the better it is for you and then you've
got to make that call and there's a lot
of variables you can take in
consideration
you know one way or the other you know
some people say hey i'm only going to
trust my gut other people say that i'm
only going to trust the numbers
what the analytic data says but i think
you've got
it there's great tools and then you got
to make sure you have the right user
use it and that's what kind of presents
make sure we have all the information it
is kind of ironic you get to this point
i wonder how many people can
thank their jobs and and really souped
up titles of billy bean writing that
book
it seems like he's created a whole
industry
and inflated it with uh you know
everybody using analytics and some
people don't know what they're what that
means when they say it but
no so what is it i guess then what does
it mean to you uh for those who might
need that sort of description what what
does that
do more you know it depends on what
you're using for in terms of scouting or
you're turning on situational data it's
just more information and some
some better than others and every team
that you know it's got some
some programs they use or you know
people they hire
and i just think it's part of the
decision making process and so that's
why i will use it here
and then obviously many coaches who who
are in this league
who um who played uh the sport
not many of them uh not many of them
come from the line
uh you you played offensive line you
were guard
and then uh you had some time on the
defensive side of a line how
how do you think that um gives you uh
maybe a little bit of an
advantage or a different perspective as
being a head coach in the nfl
yeah it certainly gives you a different
perspective you know like you can't
speak for other
guys i mean there's been great coaches
that have come to the quarterback
position that seems usually a pretty
fast track for
for play callers and and head coaches
but there's other guys that have done it
from different spots
uh you know obviously uh braves the guy
mike rabel got just worked for him mike
was a defensive guy but he could
he could coach on any position on the
field and he had a great mind for it
and then you know guys i've looked up to
i don't know andy reid but certainly
i've always looked up to him because he
was a lineman yep well and uh
so you see guys do it from other other
spots guys i learned from that did it
from the tight end room
that certainly helped uh but yeah you
use all those
all those experiences are valuable okay
uh and so does that mean uh
there's a little bit of taylor lawan in
you or you and taylor lujan
what do you think i was wondering if you
have you been on the bus yet i have not
uh coached part of the reason why part
of the reason why
is i've called taylor out for the bus
not being able to actually run
you know like like i told him once he
has a motor in the bus
and that he does actually put the bus on
the road
that's when i'll show up you know i have
a certain level and certain standard
that i need to
you know normally i do make an exception
for michigan man like taylor
right but i'm just shocked you haven't
been on there yet well i mean
no this is not it's not anything i've
made my position known to him i mean he
knows
and my favorite thing was also uh saying
that he was the full host of it ignoring
will compton completely
that's one of my favorite favorite
things to do
[Laughter]
that's just me that's my own speed hey
coach thanks for joining i appreciate
this
hopefully this will be many different uh
ways for
for for us to communicate and um and
you'd be you'd be well good luck to you
thanks rich you guys appreciate you
having me on you better talking soon
right back at you that's arthur smith
the atlanta falcons right here on the
rich eisen show hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here